hello oh goodbye hello everybody my name
is Markiplier and welcome back
shadow of Rose I still don't know where
the access point to get to the other
missions that you play other characters
in the game to do the thing with the
lady
but I'll find that out later because I
have much to do here and so I will do
just that I don't know how and where
that big guy went
seems like there wasn't a door big
enough to fit him but hopefully he's not
right here oh
rest
what
what's wrong oh you know everything
of this was supposed to happen
no the reason I came here hasn't changed
I need that Crystal
thank you a sodi pop oh
thank you
oh that was awfully nice I guess maybe I
should have been
kind of
smoother with that conversation but I
wasn't so I'm not going to remorse
anything that I've ever done
all right but I have one mask and
you there you go
oh your hair oh no it's never mind I
thought it was something else
okay is there a save
there's a save over there I can go here
and then I can go up there next which I
will but I'm Gonna Save first
right I forgot about all that
um
all right interesting oh isn't it wasn't
this a safer I think this was a safe
room and had one of those weird physics
ball puzzles
hello
hi the big guy was here
in a previous existence I swear he was
ooh I can't open that
but what I can do uh hopefully safe no I
do not recall a single thing not who I
am nor how I came to be I know nothing
my memories are as broken as the face I
hide behind this mask All That Remains
is this feeling this hunger to see
others in pain the despair in their eyes
the sounds of their screams who will be
not my next Quarry I have my minion to
do my bidding he has many faces but no
brains within those skulls he's my best
hound and equal Chase those rabbits down
ah so this is the Memoir of the big guy
whatever his name really was
so I can't get in there just yet because
I need to figure out how to get in those
big key cases
but
if there's not another thing to do here
there is another one of those things to
burn
down here or I can't get to it
well you win some you lose some and I've
lost this one okay
so where was this I see it over there
but I can't get over there door's all
gooped up
[Music]
yeah
well there's no need to have an attitude
about it
okay door
weird engine thing
good oh safe here
am I
tired
what about you
[Music]
try not to overdo it then
we have such a close Bond you and I I
care very much about the mysterious
being writing words
okay but am I actually supposed to rest
here or what what's the deal what's the
dealio
I guess not interesting
can fluid oh paintings uh butterfly
something spider
well that's good the Predators Stand
United each staring down their prey oh
oh I get it each staring down their prey
I see okay
so let's think about this fixed in place
can't be removed
I mean the frog is well the Frog wants
the
no the frog doesn't want that no no no
[Music]
there are things behind these yes wolves
is fixed wolves want sheep that much I
know there are skulls and bones there's
the butterfly wants to flower it's too
true to be true the Frog wants the
spider
does the Frog want the spider
what happened did I do it ah no no no no
no no no
doesn't the isn't isn't it a thing where
the butterfly would want the flower and
that that's kind of like a little tricky
trick you know isn't that the trick
am I missing one I might be missing a
painting or I might be really really
dumb
key
let me go down this way first
oh
damn I'm good
damn I'm good
also they can't have us in this manner
without
well I'm sorry to interrupt your meal
didn't mean that
five with all headshots
which is very whoa where are you there
you are it's five with all head shots
which if I can get those head shots then
everything is going to be good
holy crap oh my God no thank you oh TV
that's new
okay oh God oh God oh God not that way
oh [ __ ]
oh my
where is it the monocular key was
supposed to be here somewhere it's not
in this room though it must be close by
must it be oh
don't go too weak
how dare you
dare you behind fireplace I knew that
oh holy crap
how did you do that
could you always do that
I mean if I remember correctly you were
deleting entire sections of walls which
was very impressive
[Music]
don't mind if I do I'll take that I said
don't mind anybody stronger now well in
what way
how so
take this
did that
wait
this all this does is halt enemy
movements I mean
I was already able to shoot them in the
head
[Applause]
I already had incredible aim
well this is
all right is that everything in here yes
okay well good I guess I'm pretty sure
uh I guess what it could mean is that I
could run away from things if I didn't
need to fight something that would save
me bullets in the long run so that is
good
this too what are you talking about
beautiful
oh
ah I bet that only has a limited number
of uses
I will be careful
oh boy
like that
it's not open before
hello take this oh we got both of them
it got both
you got the both of them oh yeah Excuse
me while I read this as previously
discussed disrupting the auto inducers
with immune to my seat Network can have
disabling effects on the mold these
effects can also be observed and beings
formed from the mold rather than the
cellular disintegration observed in this
however this is instead presented as a
dramatic slowing of movement practically
freezing the being in place if other
bodies are in close proximity to the
Target disruptions respect can spread
but only within a very limited sphere of
influence okay don't buy me goodbye did
I get everything I hope I did oh hey
what's up uh excuse me pardon me oh my
god oh hey what's up take this Ah that's
what you get
I hope I'm using those effectively but I
don't want to be like one of you and not
use the things oh stop
stop take that
oh shooty
oh my God they're right behind me oh my
God oh my God okay no they're fine it's
it's all good it's all good
it's all good where are they where am I
supposed to go Gallery was I supposed to
go in here I believe yes no maybe so oh
the paintings
oh I didn't know
yo it's Gotta Be oh It's gotta be it's
gotta be missing something gotta be
missing one I'm not dumb it's missing
one
it's the only answer
it's the only answer everybody else shut
up why is there no save point
where was the last hit point there was
before I go that way there was a case
with one eye on it down here I'm gonna
get that before I move on I know that if
uh there's a door with like one eye on
it and so if I get that it'll probably
let me progress and find a safe spot but
there was a case in here and I can't
forget about that
monocular I unlocked it
oh that's probably good I guess uh
increased Firepower somehow
all right I trust that not 100 sure how
that works but I trust it
good all right so what I do next is I go
through the door the binocular door the
one-eyed door and then I
I'm gonna ignore the sound that I heard
off to my right what do you want stay
safe
how so
I'm trying but it's hard when I'm being
hunted by A demented Giant and it's
creepy
creeper I guess I can't fight them all
I mean I did already discover that I was
already uh it's not cowardice it's
strategy and I was already doing it so
you don't need to worry about me let me
worry about me you go ahead and worry
about you I'm gonna worry about me
God I hope I find a painting somewhere
it would be really embarrassing if the
solution of that was actually in front
of my face and I did not do anything to
actually get it
but I'm not thinking that that's true
can't possibly be true
hello oh goodbye
[Music]
that's probably
that's probably fine
I was probably funny I gotta see a save
anywhere here against same
save me safe oh that's bad oh that's
probably welcome to the gallery of this
succeeded in obtaining at least one mask
set your sights upon those Chosen Few
whose final moments of Despair are
preserved forever in this Gallery
witness in this collection the light of
life from a different perspective
well that's sad
bastard yep oh goodness oh great can I
take one of these paintings
sure
this is Lady domincrest boudoir
I'm using up my valuable item
well I can shoot
what do you think of this and well God
damn it still took six shots because I
missed
all the time oh I remember you oh I
remember you push
I don't know what I pushed oh God oh my
God
okay well okay it said it's a push order
puzzle although I have just drowned the
Arrows by doth sting they hang me long
ago yet I feel everything but still the
worst not last nor first the sharpest
blade did ring
okay they hang me long ago
I just drowned Okay so
okay they hang me long ago that's first
hanging first
uh
okay hanging first then either Arrow or
blade
yeah let's try this
and if this doesn't work then it's
slight alteration
okay so it wasn't that so oh unless it
wants the drowning first so hang me long
ago
and like yeah it might be the opposite
no it goes right back
no I know it's this
because it stays there it's lit
but it's not this
nah although I have just round the
arrows bite dust oh I read it wrong oh
oh
I I see I see
the wording could have been a little
better on that I blame that not me
where's a safe where the freak is a save
where's the Goddamn save why have I not
been able to save why does it not why is
there no saves why has there been no
saves I don't get it why is there no
saves how no wait there has to be a save
here
how do I get to the Parlor all right
there's got to be a save like right here
there has to be
oh boy yep there I go
save
huh
foreign
okay well I'm back here
any save
uh I'm sure there's a save point
somewhere here and if I just plow ahead
it shall be fine
don't kill don't do it oh wait no you're
not good stop you stop name of the law
in the Name of Love okay so uh oh man I
should probably free this up while
you're Frozen oh he doesn't sound very
Frozen anymore
give
him ah why would you do that to me stop
stop stop I'll pipe on you
I'll pipe you
I'll bomb your pipe that doesn't last
very long okay
all right hey anybody seen a mask down
here anybody's seen a mask anybody seen
a mask anybody seen the movie The Mask
it's an oldie but goodie oh hey what's
up no no
oh God
where do I go what do I do you you oh
don't hit me with your hammer
oh my God
how are you still alive I just killed
you
no oh okay good good good
I know I didn't kill him but honestly I
had to get out of there it was a
strategic move and I made a good one
take this give me your goodies
man my other clones suck if they can't
get through this this is so oh it's
right here
here there's nothing easy peasy
mint on something
hey I thought you were here running a
fair game I thought this was supposed to
be like a
you know I thought I was supposed to
well this is a problem
okay everyone it's a strategic movement
it's a strategic move I've make
strategic moves here this is top level
gameplay and that's all it is
stop oh God okay good oh my God no not
me oh you're a problem move behind you
oh
okay uh can I quickly do one of these
yep I can and then I'm gonna quickly do
one of these okay got them both I am a
Resident Evil God I am incredible in
every way shape and form
I am outstanding I am good I am good at
games and stuff and things and nothing
other surprises will be here for me
surprises
any surprises
no surprises good great oh surprise
I'll go this way now
[Music]
The Mask yeah I got the mask I got the
mask yeah the mask I've got the mask
I've got them out while you're asking
about the mask just barely
this ugly brute turned up
no [ __ ] I'd fight something like that
hmm
take all the help I can get thank you I
mean thank you I don't know why I'm
being so ungrateful but thank you yeah I
but I already figured that out asada
save
wow that's great okay so I got that safe
this is open there that just goes back
there though
where do you go
whoa hey well this is lovely oh
is Misty out there
like a foggy remembrance that I can't
quite remember
this
I heard footsteps did you hear footsteps
I heard footsteps
hello
scrap
uh
uh I see
all right well I've got a lot of
craftables but thankfully I've been able
to get out of most of my uh horrible
terrible things that are happening to me
any more surprises
okay but I did get everything everything
seemed to be clear in the menu or the
map
so I think I'm okay
love the gallery of Despair I rate it
very highly I'm just gonna save again I
don't have a chance to save so I guess I
gotta I knew it I freaking knew do it
all right oh
wow
lady dominant asks tub holy crap
did I see that before I don't remember
that I feel like I would have commented
on it but I did not
anywho
all right
feel like all this hinting about lady
dominates and yet there's no sight or
sound of her if this is a place of
memories I would think that the memories
would exist there
just saying well that's not good
yes I am
what is this oh no no what is it
no no yes is this the same thing
yes yeah
I seem to be doing exactly as I please
the thing they run right by me even when
I'm not looking they seem to be able to
just skate right on by
am I supposed to put the monocular key
here or what is what is the deal
I feel like this is not the right key it
needs to be a three key I probably got
to do some key mixing
before it gives me the shotgun
that's okay I'm going to put the mask
there and then I'm going to go up and
put a painting in the spot
and all will be right in the world
everything
probably
oh
beautiful and then I get the Crystal and
I get to remove the powers and I will be
a normal normal girl
that would be perfectly normal
probably
anyway hello I'm gonna do this now okay
so frog
you think you're a predator
you think no no no you are prey frog
snake
oh
goodbye
works for me thank you very much
puzzles to mess with me I don't know if
he made the puzzles at all
whoa straight to three whoa whoa
until the the golden mask shall be Grant
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] okay well that's good I like
that so I can get the shotgun now too
sure
all right
I like that
but also I have a bad feeling about this
because why did it just jump to three
why wouldn't that be one and then three
also do I not get that back
is that all it's used for
I get both
things it should you'd think they would
but it doesn't actually
also I have pipe bombs I forgot about
them
uh okay so I have those things but where
um
interesting try ocular I see it okay
back the way I came in one of the first
areas to get the first mask hey
hey
no good thing you can't earn very fast
holy crap all right
it's fine glad I broke that thing before
I'm gonna go in here now
please yes please yes thank you oh good
oh good oh good oh it's right there oh
my God this is so easy oh look at this
oh the easiest thing in the world okay
so there's got to be one of these it's
accessible from something nearby you
you I can't reach you
okay but if I can't get this right away
then there's gotta be something else I
can get in relatively soon fashion
thank you whatever that is thank you
uh
I feel like
is it
all right there we go
man that's really convenient
oh boy that's a lot of use
that's a lot of use guys
um
all right hold on here whoa whoa whoa
easy easy easy easy
you know that compensator which was
supposed to what have you and increase
the Firepower and what have didn't seem
to do that
[Applause]
still takes five shots
or more in case my aim's bad
and now I should be able to reach
another one
there must be
one would think
oh come on
that's gonna drop on my head
or it's not going to drop at all
did that just unlock this nice painting
that I can look at it's a very lovely
painting it's extremely lovely but it
doesn't help me at all
uh uh okay so I probably gotta go
upstairs oh hey
I'm good
I know I've got plenty that I could
craft so I am aware of that I'm just
going to conserve it for now in case I
need to graph something specific like
shotgun ammo
because I would much prefer to use
powerful things on the powerful enemies
when I get the chance
this is one of those things that
definitely is clearly too easy to get
this
there's no way that this is all there is
to get the masks and then I get the
Crystal and then I'm free that's
definitely not how this is going to go
however
all right excuse me
hold on I'm concentrating oh I'm
concentrating you missed me
stop
oh God oh God no oh my face
[Applause]
Oh I thought I it said mold counter I
didn't read anything it's too late but I
thought I saw that
uh there must be something that's like a
quick time event-esque thing that I
encountered right before it gets me but
I just didn't do it
uh I guess I should just maybe I should
just go about it like I make as much of
that as I can otherwise I just go about
it normally
I don't know why this one took so long
to be able to douche
it's like he was trying to get me but
whatever I'm not mad and I'm mad at all
all right
anything else in here hello
where do you go where is this where am I
back here how did I get back here
all right that's good I do know all
these returns I never know if they're
good or bad I don't know anything about
them
I don't have any confidence in anything
that I'm doing one two skip a few 99 the
mask is um
I have it
I have it don't cut scene me I have it I
have the thing easy peasy don't cut
seeing me and make me lose it I have it
it's in my butt pocket
fix right in for some reason
oh my sick biceps oh God I worked them
so oh god oh no
well that's a problem oh good it didn't
kill me
that was awfully merciful of it
um
[Music]
claiming your crystalline prize
I knew the real s would be so much more
lively
it would be a shame to Snuff you out so
unceremoniously shall we prolong our fun
a little longer
oh come now don't pout I've prepared a
nice little diversion for you
oh man is horoscia nearly all of them
are counterfeit
do you think you can suss out the real
one sauce out the real one
okay I'm gonna use my big brain on this
there's definitely
to tell the difference
what is this
because there's got to be something with
this right
what's that about
I'll help oh okay
lower the barrel lower than Barrel
right left lower than Barrel okay Barrel
lower than Barrel U
h
[Music]
yes oh
hey
oh next one oh God
or I can just guess
broken wall
deep Shadow ah
deep Shadow oh God don't go in there go
go
what's with you
oh God
I don't know what you mean by Deep
shadow
Oak oh I got it never mind
deep shadow that was weird
I don't know what you're talking about
hurry I you know I would love to
follow my words here up
here up oh wait it's obvious
I think it's uh yeah
[Music]
I did it the sclerosure
thank you
thank you
me all right whatever oh good save you
did it I did it
I did it I couldn't have done it without
you I literally couldn't have
not at all the truth I was hoping for a
pony but I guess this will do all right
whatever make a pony out of mold make a
moldony
oh okay now I'll never have to look at
that again all right well that's great
um good I have remasks and then I will
get the Crystal and then all my Powers
will be gone forever and then I will be
a normal person
just like I always wanted so thank you
everybody for joining me on my journey
to become a normal person
hope you enjoyed it
someday I'll be normal